there's a line and I'm going to  paraphrase it from Machiavelli's the  prince you know 500 years old but  everybody remembers it where he says  that if a prince must commit atrocities  he should commit them early  and and so I always kind of think of  that that Elon has this sort of period  right now where when I'm calling for  don't do this piecemeal this like set up  some system of well we'll do this one  we'll do Babylon we'll no blanket  amnesty yeah  overturn every single permanent ban on  Twitter make everyone when they come  back they hold on hold on they have to  redo their terms of service they have to  sign up again they have to go through  the process they have to follow it but  my point is release the release the  prisoners of war from the great meme war  of 2015 2016 immediately let my people  go